for decades the so-called space race was
dominated by superpowers pouring
government funds
into conquering the final frontier now
it's all about
billionaires like richard branson elon
musk and jeff bezos
each have formed their own companies
vying for lucrative contracts
and plans to take tourists beyond
earth's orbit
so far none of the tycoons has boarded
their own rockets
next month bezos plans to change that i
want to go on this flight
because it's a thing i've wanted to do
all my life
the launch planned for july the 20th
will see bezos his brother
and the winner of an online auction
climb aboard a new shepard rocket
if all goes well the 11 minute flight
will see the passengers reach the edge
of space
before returning to earth it's being
seen by many as a potential triumph over
rivals
branson and musk so yeah there's
probably a little bit of like ego
involved but
but there's probably genuine passion
there too i mean all all
like three of these people have been at
this now for the better part of
of two decades so i think yeah i mean i
think there is like genuine interest and
like genuine passion there too
that passion has come at a price for all
three entrepreneurs but former
astronauts say
these commercial projects could make
space flight a reality for those that
can afford it
i don't know if space travel in our
lifetimes is ever going to become
quite as as popular as airplane travel
but nevertheless
it's going to give a lot more people the
opportunity to experience
what i and my fellow astronauts have
experienced the new shepard rocket has
successfully carried out 15 missions to
the edge of space
albeit without passengers with bezos on
board the new space race
could be about to get even more
competitive
the rivalry between jeff bezos and elon
musk has been
simmering for years their sparring
matches on social media are there for
all to see
but in marketing terms this could be a
victory for the founder of amazon
question is what will elon musk do to
top his rival's
latest move no one knows but the world
is watching andy gallacher al-jazeera
miami florida